[Music]
this morning we want to tell you about a
chance encounter that changed the life
of cbs sunday morning correspondent
martha teichner
martha writes about adopting a bull
terrier named harry
and the profound connection with his
previous owner carol
who was battling cancer in her new book
when harry met
minnie martha was looking for a
companion for her dog minnie
she talks about the remarkable
circumstances that led to the new
friendships
on cbs sunday morning oh you have your
card oh that's enough suddenly i spotted
an old dog walking acquaintance i hadn't
seen in a year or two
and had never seen at the farmer's
market
stephen miller siegel with his golden
retriever
i walked up to you and i said hi martha
you know how are you where is
your other dog a few months before goose
minnie's companion for most of her life
had died
you said i'm looking for an older male
because minnie is lonely
and it was almost as if like the heavens
had opened up
why because carol fertig a friend of
stevens for 30 years
was dying of liver cancer the result of
living practically next door to ground
zero
in the aftermath of 9 11. nobody wanted
her 11 and a half year old dog
harry she had made me promise that if we
couldn't find a home for harry
that i would put him down which was
an extremely difficult conversation to
have with her
if i'd been standing somewhere else if
i'd been there at 8 45
instead of 8 30 if it had been raining
and minnie and i had stayed home stephen
would not have seen us and none of this
would ever have happened
looking through my phone there are
glimpses of carol
beat up by a girl as the dog's courtship
heated up and visits to my apartment
became frequent
we were like mothers playing matchmaker
and long after harry and minnie actually
fell in love
we kept on playing because carol and i
quickly became close friends
carol lost her battle with cancer in
2016 and harry
lived out the rest of his time with
martha and minnie unhilt
until he died martha teuchner joins us
now martha good morning this is
this is such a lovely story uh and such
an amazing chance encounter as you point
out
just minutes could have changed how this
all played out did it change your view
of fate
well i've had a number of similar kinds
of fateful
right place at the right time kinds of
encounters in my life that have made a
big difference so i'm already a big
believer in fate you said carol's
friendship gave you
insight into being open to opportunity
tell us about that
well not always
is it possible or do we think about
saying yes to opportunities that come
along
and maybe it would be easier to just
let slip by and i found myself
just almost instinctively saying yes and
i
ended up having an experience a set of
experiences that
so enriched my life even though there
was sadness associated with it that
i just felt like i had been given
a huge gift you said that you wrote the
book
because you didn't want to stop living
the story what did you mean
well it was so concentrated and so
meaningful to me
and carol was such a special person and
the circumstances were so extraordinary
that i treasured every minute of it
and i wrote the book because as
i was writing immersing myself back in
the story
concentrating in order to write it it
was like i was
reliving it and kind of experiencing a
movie almost and
and uh i didn't have to let it go i
could just
drop back in at any time i wanted yeah
and we don't have to let it go either
because it's
it's all there now in a really lovely
book uh martha teichner thank you so
much
when harry met minnie is on sale today